if you are confident without data you
delusional like you're a faker you're
either faking it or you're copy pasting
someone else's experience cuz otherwise
where would you get the data from you
get it from somebody else that you heard
which means you're irrelevant they
probably said it better cuz they did it
so just like stop and go do your own
thing go back in the trenches go do the
Reps and then when you come back you
will feel confident because you will
have quote outworked yourself out which
is really giving yourself undeniable
proof because like I don't like the the
chest beating thing and so if someone
isn't confident it might be right for
them to be unconfident